this is what happens to your body when
you're sleep-deprived there's a lot of
ways sleep deprivation can wreck your
body but let's talk about the big ones
we've all pulled all-nighters thinking
the helpless ace the big test but they
don't actually help when you sleep
pathways form between the neurons in
your brain helping you remember new
information a process called
consolidation so if you don't sleep
you're less likely to remember stuff
than you would have if you snooze
possibly ruining your chance of passing
AP History don't look at me also
whenever you stay up late the next day
you find it difficult to concentrate
that's because you've hindered your
cells ability to function properly when
you deprive your body of sleep the
activity between nerve cells of your
brains temporal lobe can slow down and
fire more weakly this leads to the brain
being slow to respond to stimuli or
instructions your body also has a harder
time fighting off infection when it
hasn't got enough disease the immune
system produces proteins called
cytokines which help regulate sleep
inflammation and immune reactions a lack
of sleep tips bounce toward inflammation
promoting cytokines which are linked to
chronic conditions like heart disease
and it reduces the body's ability to
fight off infections this means you can
get sick easier and it may take longer
for you to recover is everyone so
annoying when you haven't got enough
sleep yeah that's you not them sleep
helps regulate the same
neurotransmitters in the brain that
affect mood thus sleep deprivation can
mess with how you feel
for example sleep deprivation impacts
brain chemicals like norepinephrine
dopamine and serotonin which are
associated with mood and behavior those
chemicals can be thrown off balance when
you don't sleep leading to mood swings
you're already in a bad mood because you
didn't get any sleep and then you look
in the mirror and think oh do I really
look that bad yes yes you do when you're
sleep-deprived your body tends to
release more cortisol a stress hormone
that can affect skin cells and promote
inflammation over time this may
contribute to aging lack of sleep can
also lead to overeating
sleep has an impact on the level of the
hormones leptin and ghrelin leptin curbs
your appetite making you feel full and
ghrelin increases your appetite making
you hungry
sleep deprivation reduces leptin and
raises ghrelin which might help explain
late night snacking so thanks to sleep
deprivation you can't focus
you have delayed reactions your mood is
all over the place and you look like a
zombie in a beer or film you're in luck
though there's an easy fix for teenagers
8 to 10 hours of sleep are recommended
adults between 18 to 64 years of age
should get between 7 to 9 hours and
older adults over 65 years old only need
seven to eight hours are you a baby you
need 14 to 17 hours of sleep why are you
watching this video go to sleep baby as
for the rest of you if you have a time
machine please go back and tell your
college-age self to go to bed trust me
your under eye bags will thank you
you
[Music]